as we approach Black History Month the
city of Las Vegas is honoring several
people in our community for their work
and dedication to the valley Victoria
Saha reports on the Ninth Annual
African-American Trailblazer Service
Awards
a room full of cheer and hope at the Las
Vegas city hall an awards ceremony held
to honor those who are truly
trailblazing through our community as a
rememberable Black History Month
although Black History Month is
celebrated next month I celebrate 365 24
7. this Trailblazer award ceremony
celebrated five people who have been
Pioneers in their own unique path with a
theme of resiliency but when I I look
around
this year's business and economic
advancement award went to Melvin green
founder of kme Architects kami's motto
is we listen
we pay attention we create and we
deliver his notable projects include the
restoration of the historic west side
and the community activism and politics
award went to Tamika Henry who's
described as a champion for underserved
communities she serves as a director for
about a collective ending
multi-generational poverty with
resources and an urban farm on the west
side I do the work because
I want to be who I needed when I was at
my lowest we will have access to Fresh
Produce in the historic West Side for
our families the educator Award winner
kuchandra James whose passion for Arts
inspires her students the 2023 Tyrone
Thompson emerging leader award went to
author and poet Vogue Robinson who was
already a Trailblazer before receiving
this award and is the first black woman
all right to receive the pen the silver
pen award from the Nevada water writers
Hall of Fame on the 2023 spiritual
Community Award winner Reverend Dr Nadia
Parson closing remarks ended with a
standing ovation to the many generations
that came before these Trailblazers in
Parks but they went to their grave
holding on to the fact that the Lord was
going to see us through Victorious aha 8
news now during the ceremonies
councilman Cedric Greer announced the
next group of honorees who will be
installed in the historic us signed a
Legacy Park during the 2023 Juneteenth
holiday you can find that complete list
on our website eightnusenow.com